Kyle the the challenge like today if a
person really wanted to run for office
and they got up and they said well
listen here's what we're going to be
doing folks everybody's got to get back
to work you got to do your part you got
to improve some skills you got to learn
two or three skills next 12 months
hopefully five new skills the next two
years and we think you can increase your
market value but we are so much in debt
we can't give any more entitlement
programs we're not going to be doing any
more buildbacks better nothing for eight
years we're not spending any more money
than we are right now we're in the
business of cutting down expenses today
just like a company we're supposed to
cut down expenses right now we have way
too much debt do you know if somebody
ran on that you know it's the chances of
that person winning no chance probably
zero zero because what's popular today
is what Andrew Yang says what Bernie
Sanders says what Biden says what
Elizabeth Warren says what anybody says
that we're going to give it to you if
you vote me in for free we are more and
more and more gradually becoming an
entitled Nation
and that's a scary thought because
eventually something has to happen with
all this money we can't constantly be
giving money away to people it is very
attractive this is why kids love their
grandparents because grandparents
secretly give chocolate away to kids and
parents don't if I see my daughter what
goodies are people getting like I don't
see the working class is struggling I
just told you 63 of people are living
paycheck to pay and people are doing
that they're not in a good place right
now then that tells you we were doing a
shitty job spending people's money goes
back to my point that the money being
given to the government they don't know
what to do with the money because we're
definitely not slowing down giving money
to the government there's another 1.7
trillion dollars last week we're not
like saying no to it here here's more of
our money let's see what you're gonna do
with it they don't do good with it again
let's give you a little bit more money
again they don't do good with it if if
as an investor you deal with your
financial advisor you're gonna have a
financial advisor you probably have a
financial advisor and you're going to
fire some financial advisors okay and
some of them you think a lot of about
what they do with your money if you
don't think about what your financial
advisor is doing with your money guess
what it's because he's probably doing a
good job right you're like okay listen I
get the right returns he protects me
calls me saying hey here's what happened
I suggest moving this money from here to
bonds because we think the next six
months going to go this hey I think
we're ready to go into equities are you
comfortable for going to equity is great
and then there are some that never call
you there are people in your life you
trust a waiter you trust hey I like my
sd9010 I got you Pat he brings it how is
it good never ask him again because the
guy knows how to make your iced tea or
Arnold Palmer hey here's how I like my
steak medium you ever had to order the
medium and they bring you well done how
annoyed you are when you cut the meat
and you're like dude I said medium this
is well done right you don't trust that
restaurant okay
the government has a very low trust in
the marketplace with what they do with
the money and this doesn't go on Bernie
Sanders because a Bernie Sanders getting
elected isn't all of a sudden going to
clean house with all the employees and
bring in the people that we're going to
trust that's going to do the job because
Bernie's not going to be doing the job
Trump's not gonna it's gonna be the
people on the inside that are going to
be doing the job so that's the challenge
when it goes back to what we do with the
money they have a very low credibility
score of what they do unless we agree
public trust in the government yeah
today let me address this yeah because
on this we 100 agree
um as somebody who believes in social
democracy I mean I think somebody would
have to be high to think that I support
this current government I mean the
problem is from the 1970s until today
there's been a number of Supreme Court
cases which have effectively legalized
bribery legalized corruption
um there was the Buckley versus Vallejo
case the McCutchen case the citizens
united case and this is just fancy legal
speak of saying
um they decided it is uh the same as
free speech rights for a billionaire or
a corporation to donate to politicians
so when you bring up your concern of
like look what the [ __ ] going on with
all this money like they you know the
government keeps doing stuff and people
don't see improvements in their everyday
life I think that's a million percent
correct and the reason is you have the
military industrial complex big Pharma
the for-profit health insurance
companies Wall Street individual
billionaires they pay the politicians
then the politicians turn around and
pass legislation that helps out those
special interests those lobbyists it
doesn't help out the working people so
of course we're we're 100 in agreement
on that and I think the solution on that
front if you want good governance if you
want a government that actually
represents the people more where you can
see it's all accountable and you see
where the money is going and it's all
going to positive places there's
something called clean elections which
effectively is taking the private
financing out of the election system so
no more corporate donations no more
billionaire donations the way it works
is there's a process to determine who
gets on the ballot and then once you're
on the ballot it's uh funded by the
taxpayers and then you have a genuine
real true battle of ideas and policies
and disagreements and it's no longer a
battle of competing factions where for
example it's like well you know the
Democrats are bought by the these this
lawyer group or these unions and the
Republicans are bought by this hedge
fund and and so whoever ends up winning
the election guess who's going to get
served either the hedge fund or the
Earth of course right yes yeah but we're
on the same place say this is right why
this is why I'm for Trump and Bernie
because neither one of them are bought
okay and whatever they're gonna say is
whatever they're gonna say and they got
the voters to come in we had Paul
manafort here I don't what it was four
months ago five months ago and I said I
don't like lobbyists because you guys
are messing everything up right yeah you
know how much money these guys make
it's ungodly some of these guys are
making 10 20 million dollars you're
doing what they're doing but here's
here's what one thing uh that's I again
I think we're gonna agree on this one
here so Elon buys Twitter okay which we
haven't even gotten to the Twitter
conversation to see what your thoughts
are on that but Elon buys Twitter they
got 7 500 employees
immediately he cuts 50 so go to 37.50
they cut 37.50 the 37.50 that were cut
recruit the other 1200 to quit so 37.50
gets another 1200 so he's not lost 5 000
okay
7 500 employees to 2500 employees and
Twitter's done more advancement in the
last two months of additional things on
Twitter that you've seen the last two
three years now what do you like the
features or not it's irrelevant it's
things are being updated right it's like
quickly things are being updated Twitter
went from being a slow large you know a
social government social media company
to announce going back to the startup
things moving very very quickly right
the amount of organizations we have in
in the government that have ten thousand
fifty thousand hundred thousand
employees that can be run on a tenth of
that that you're seeing by the way uh uh
Facebook other companies are seeing what
Twitter is doing they're like dude maybe
we don't need a hundred thousand
employees maybe we don't need fifty
thousand we don't only what and by the
way these salaries are not like it's
twenty thousand dollar your salary
seventy thousand dollar your salaries
these are guys making 180 150 200 250
000 a year salary so we're also learning
that wasted money in free enterprise
people are starting to realize we can do
more work with fewer people that's not
good for people that want to raise
minimum wage but also in the government
every time we need uh 80 how many
thousand IRS agents that they just hire
87 000. and they're saying with the 87
jobs by the way with guns 87 000 IRS
agents we're gonna did you see what
number they give we're gonna be able to
collect another trillion dollars of tax
money to be fair they say that's for
people who make 400 000 and over they're
saying that they're saying that but good
luck going and spending some money and
getting a 700 bill on something you did
on you know PayPal or any of that stuff
you're still getting that 700 tax bill
they're still going and collecting that
money from the people 87 000 Irish
agents for what how does that sell me to
dream how does that sell me to dream
what are you saying to people we're
going to collect money you really need
87 000 of them well see the problem is
under the previous administrations I
think going all the way back to Bill
Clinton but it may have been from Obama
and onward there's been effectively like
a war on the IRS where they've fired a
tremendous number of them so getting
back these 87 000 is not even getting
back to you know what it was however
many years ago do you think we need more
IRS agencies to go after the wealthy
yeah because right now I agree with your
point about the IRS kind of harassing
working people and going after people
make forty thousand dollars a year or
whatever it is no I don't want to go
after those people and I like I told you
I think those people should get a tax
cut if anything else I think they should
have more money yes I definitely think
we should reign in the oligarchs for
sure and you need the IRS how big are
the old how many oligarchs well I would
Define the old oligarchs as what we just
described before which is the
billionaires and corporations who pay
the government their campaigns 87 000 to
go after 500 people well no I mean not
just the oligarchs I'm talking about but
that's which is the top one percent but
yeah but if you I think you should go
after basically the top one percent
including the oligarch so are you are
you part of top one percent right now uh
I'm probably part of the top five
percent okay but you're gonna be in the
top one percent very soon maybe maybe
not we'll see there's no question about
it you keep working buddy you'll be
there there's no question capitalism has
given you a very good life and you I I
think if you keep continuing you'll be
in the top point one percent so we
believe in you Kyle's what we're trying
to say I'm saying I'm saying the
government should tax the [ __ ] out of me
that's what I think
you know uh I make six figures at the
moment um I wouldn't put myself in the
top bracket but yeah I mean so what's
your tax rate like be real what's your
tax rate right now you're in New York
probably I mean New York has kind of
high state taxes and so let's say you
make 200 Grand a year okay so you're
paying a hundred grand in taxes uh
probably closer to like 85 okay
something like that so what are you
comfortable paying you know I think I
think that's a fair rate so what happens
what happens if they took 10 more I
would probably switch it up in terms of
what percentage goes to the federal
government versus what percentage goes
to the state government
um I I'm kind of a believer in a more uh
centralized system I don't like the how
you have so many layers of government
where each one can tax you and they do
different things I'm a big fan of
centralization in the sense that you
know it should be the same rules in
Kentucky as it is in in New York in a
sense but yeah in terms of the amount of
money that I'm taxed sure if that if you
tell me that money is going towards
Healthcare education Pre-K but I'm
saying but you know what you're saying
entertainment yeah
you're saying you don't trust the people
that are getting your money today that's
what you're saying yeah but nobody and
that's correct so that's right we all
agree on that but if we don't why give
them more because we're trying to make
it so that money goes towards good
things to reallocate it and that's what
I'm fighting for the daily basis but
it's not the point though but you don't
do but I would be a hypocrite if I said
you know what I'm in favor raising taxes
on all these people but you know what
cut my taxes even though I make
something that's not the point but but
what we have uh things that we agree
with we don't agree who's getting the
money because they don't have a track
record of doing the right thing with the
money they're already getting from us we
totally agree on that okay so so so to
to do you know like to fix that what we
have to do if it's a lot of work if U.S
was a corporation you have to fire 50 of
the existing people and then bring newer
people in who have ethics to clean it up
that actually have to do the work
because the existing people are not
they're in a swamp type of an
environment that they've been getting
away for a while and no president's
going to be able to fix that the more if
there was anything that we did like if
the last person that said give us this
money and we'll give the money back was
a guy named Abraham Lincoln I think it's
1872 or whatever the year was he says
hey we're going to tax you guys 10 for
the next however many years and then
once we pay off the money we got from
the award the debt then we're going to
stop taxing you guess what happened
after Abraham Lincoln when he did that
they collected the debt they stopped
taxing okay that's how tax was we'll
collect the money will pay off the debt
and will not tax again until 1913. hey
let's FDR let's start taxing everybody
that's a cool way before FDR that was an
FTR no when Lincoln did it it was uh
1872 of course it's before FDR but yeah
but when taxes came in it's like hey
let's keep taxing taxing FDR brought
minimum wage 25 cents an hour and then
boom you know he did what he did but the
point is that's what taxes was we know
where it went to today nobody you're
talking about Pentagon five this the
fifth time yeah nobody trusted where the
money is going to right so if if you and
I don't trust an institution that has
shown zero credibility on what to do
with the money we're already being given
them for decades you want us to give
them more money well we're saying the
same thing I'm saying in an ideal system
yeah I should be taxed if you make six
figures or if you make if you're a
millionaire if you're a billionaire yeah
I think their taxes should be Steep and
I think they're still they'll still be
just fine but I think that money should
go towards the thing we've discussed
over and over in this podcast
I understand that but this is what I'm
saying we need to do both things we need
to try to fight for that world and also
I'm not going to sit here and say my tax
rate should be zero my tax rate should
be ten percent or something because then
I would be a massive hypocrite everybody
would be right to dunk which is first
though which is I don't think so I think
I think you're 34. January 31st I think
you're trying to do them yes I think
you're trying to do them simultaneously
I don't think you can do that though I
think I think in life you're gonna go
through a lot of philosophical changes
it's what's you're going to be like okay
[ __ ] things change what was this all
about well that's not cool but what is
this you're gonna if you're the same at
44 as you are 34 there's problems right
it's not going to happen to it if I'm
the same at 50 for as I am today I
wasted it 10 years of my life I'm gonna
have some changes that happen in my life
for me first starts off with
accountability then when you earn trust
with me then I'll give you more taxes
not the other way around first you have
to prove to me that you're now doing the
right thing with the money then you come
out and say cool you want to go to this
listen man you've proven you do the
right thing here's another five percent
because the last 10 years you've proved
me wrong I didn't trust you but the last
10 years look how responsible you've
been with the money that you've had and
we lowered it for you now you want to
bump a little bit more let's talk about
I understand that I agree with all of it
but nobody should be worried about me is
my point I'm not the person who's
hurting the person who's hurting is the
person who makes 20K a year when they
will work full-time a year when they
work full time so that's my main point
but that's exactly market value for the
YouTuber who does phenomenally well for
running his mouth for a living no but
but I but I also think I think uh you're
living in a state that has shown to have
zero responsibility what they do with
the money you're not living in a state
that's doing a good job with the money I
lived in California 20 for a long time
20 some years
I lived in Texas five years and I came
to Florida two years ago I've been here
for two years it's not even two years
yet right it'll be two years yeah your
birthday is going to be two years okay
happy birthday yeah thank you very much
so but but the point is we came here
we were building our media company I
just sold my insurance company six
months ago so I'm sitting there saying
where do I move the media company to I
didn't want to leave it in Dallas
uh we looked at Greenwich okay we're
gonna go to not Connecticut not New York
we're going to go to New York and then
we looked at uh Newport Newport Beach
because I'm from L.A and I like Newport
Beach and then we looked at Texas
Nashville and then last minute Florida
we're looking at Tampa and we looked at
South Florida I didn't go to I didn't go
to New York because it was a [ __ ] show
with the way they handled covid uh taxes
no matter how much taxes you give them
they keep raising it California top of
the chain with taxes you know first time
since 1851 California's lost net net
with amount of people they have their
people leaving that place they don't
trust California Tennessee I lived in
Tennessee for two years I don't want to
go to when I was in the Army I was I
lived in Tennessee for a couple I love
Tennessee but I kind of wanted to have a
little bit of the lifestyle with the
money and then I saw the santis handle
things in the State of Florida I said
yeah there's a place to move down to
because his policies earned the trust of
me moving my family so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of value men it says future
looks bright here future looks bright
here we got them in white we got them in
Black we got them in red our black on
black sold out these are about to sell
out if you haven't ordered one yet we
had a person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat specially
during times like this because ain't
nobody saying future looks bright toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]